[Music]
hmm
hi i'm russell impellatso and it's my
honor and pleasure
to be talking at the simons institute
with
dick carp who is just completing his
five-year term as the inaugural director
of the institute
so dick also is
probably the most influential person
uh researcher in theoretical computer
science
and one of the most influential
researchers
in all of computer science so um
so uh as i said this is really an honor
to be
talking to you about your career well
thank you i'm not sure i recognize
myself in the
description but any i'm delighted that
you came up from san diego to
take part in this event and i look
forward to your
your questions so how did you get
interested in computation i was a failed
math major
i was as an undergraduate i uh took the
all the courses for the math major and
when i got up to sort of graduate level
mathematics
uh there were people in the classes who
clearly were had a greater aptitude for
it than i did
what i didn't know at the time was that
one of them was a
was going to win a fields medal and
another one won a nobel prize
um harvard was the kind of place where
math prodigies sort of
popped out of the woodwork and
so i
began taking courses in the computation
lab
which had been founded by professor
howard aiken who created some of the
first
digital computers another influence was
that
my mother told me that data processing
was going to be
the you know the future the plastics
of the future and then i should i should
uh
sort of get into it so i hope your
mother invested in the stock market
no no she was very cautious she bought
government bonds
so uh so i began moving my
interests into the computation lab
and i managed to take all of the
theoretical courses they offered there
weren't very many of them i managed to
minimize my participation in courses
that involved
soldering or other laboratory activities
because i knew that
that was not my metier
and i
i realized that even though the subject
was not well developed
there was a great potential and things
were happening
ibm was dominating the computer field
and
it was clear that um computation was
uh going to be incredibly important in
society
and um how did you think of
you know when you sort of characterized
your work to other people
what did you just how did you describe
yourself
um i guess i would say that i liked
discrete or finite mathematics that i'd
like the algorithms that i had
a bent for probabilistic reasoning
and i was also very influenced by
the developments in operations research
which was a a
a budding field after its use in world
war ii
and and so i took one of my favorite
courses was
on computational methods and operations
research and again the discrete nature
of those
models and the fact that probability was
involved
made it very comfortable for me and i i
did well enough to
gain the attention of some of the
faculty and uh
that fortified my my interest
so um this is somewhat of a digression
from the kind of historical record but
um uh so there's kind of like a
a wave within computer science and maybe
moving back
towards continuous mathematics so
traditionally just what you said
discrete mathematics has been thought of
as the mathematics that's involved in
computation right
but there's kind of been a synthesis
going
showing a lot of relationships between
discrete mathematics and continuous
mathematics
does this seem like a step forward or a
step back well i think it's a wonderful
development i'm
i'm really thrilled by the work over the
last
seven or eight years in um
in spectral methods and uh
the realization that
solving linear solving special types of
linear systems of equations can be done
very efficiently
and lead to improved combinatorial
algorithms
i remember some years ago at carnegie
mellon
my friend gary miller told me that the
the right way to solve network flow
problems was through linear algebra and
i scoffed because i
knew very well it seemed that the best
way to solve those problems was to
push flu flow through the network of one
path at a time
and i have to concede that the linear
algebra methods really have won the day
also in optimization i think
even though in theoretical computer
science the emphasis has been on
discrete methods combined with linear
programming
and later semi-semi-definite programming
whereas in applied mathematics and
engineering there's always been a strong
activity in solving systems of equations
and minimizing functions
uh by continuous methods and uh here at
the institute we've
we're running a huge program which
brings those two schools of thought
together and it's a very exciting
development so i think it's quite
enriching
that these mathematical methods are
reconverting reconverging yeah
um so you mentioned the flow problem and
i think that was one of the
problems you you worked on a lot um
both i guess in the uh you know sort of
when computer science it was a very
instrumental in getting
[Music]
sort of the ground rules established for
algorithm design
but it's also like a still a
cutting-edge
research topic so um do you think the
flow problem is
is somehow special and or is it just
a historical accident that has been
played such a pivotal role well it's
such a beautiful example of some general
principles the
the uh it's a it's a special type of
linear program whose
extreme points are integers so that that
makes it very special
linear programming duality and the use
of prices and so forth
really was first illustrated in in the
context of the network flow problem and
it's a
continuing theme um it's also
it's it's an example of a problem that's
in
np intersect co-np by virtue of its
formulation as a linear program
and i just
my favorite algorithm is probably the
hungarian algorithm for solving
transportation problems or matching
problems
where it advances inexorably to the
solution
this is the old-fashioned way rather
than the linear algebra way
by modifying a flow so
it's just a beautiful example i one of
the first
books i read in operations research was
the book by ford fulkerson on network
flow problems
yeah um so
when i teach network flow to to i guess
either undergraduates or graduate
students
uh i often like use it as a precursor to
np completeness
right because in addition to being a
beautiful problem and
and important in its own sake it's also
a problem where you have
many surprising reductions uses
of network flow to solve problems that
don't seem at all related to network
flow
right you could even figure out whether
a baseball team is mathematically
eliminated using
using that workflow i don't know that
one but
yeah um did
did you do you think that um looking at
the different applications of
problems like network flow sort of put
you in a
in a good mindset too you know to
anticipate np completeness when it came
along
well i think there were some other
experiences that
brought home to me the um the
possibility of combinatorial explosions
um the my first uh assignment at ibm was
to
work on algorithms for in programs for
digital circuit minimization this was
before the age of integrated circuits
and so you had these
individual gates that cost a dollar each
and you had
you wanted to use the smallest number of
gates to compute a boolean function
and before i arrived at ibm
the group that i was that i came to join
had already had a lot of success in
solving boolean minimization
restricted to two-level circuits
oars of ands or ants aboard
map was a visual aid yeah but
they were dealing with functions in many
variables
and they had very successful
programs that didn't guarantee getting
the
cheapest solution but could do a lot
better than the engineers could do and
so that was a big hit
at ibm um so we
working with my boss at ibm john paul
roth a
mathematician we started working on
multi-level
boolean circuits and
we soon found that it was
a morass of difficulties
and we never really got a useful product
out of it
the problem was just too difficult
incidentally
the project of minimizing those circuits
also
was my first example in management
because i was cast as the
boss of a team of programmers
and that really wasn't my uh forte
because i
i sort of left left them alone for
months at a time and
uh that was a contributing factor in the
failure to generate anything useful but
anyway
that that project brought home to me
the uh seeds of a of a
combinatorial explosion but there were
many other
uh signs that that was a problem uh
if you sort of generalize uh some of the
flow problems to
uh set cover problems um
uh you eventually if you
if you try to generalize matching
to sort of three-way matching or
something like that you immediately run
into problems
where you don't have a nice
characterization and and
the combinatorial difficulties seem
overwhelming and i was aware of that i
also
worked on the traveling salesman problem
with my friend mike held
and there again we were doing
branch and bound and other uh
basically enumerative methods and
realized that
i wouldn't have been able to formulate
it very well but i realized that there
was a qualitative difference between the
tsp the traveling salesman problem
and the matching problem or the or the
flow problem
um so the so the the
circuit minimization problem trying to
find the the smallest boolean circuit
that computes a
function is so it sort of has a like a
a very rich history um so it was also
widely studied in the soviet union at
the time
around the same time i believe yes and
uh
that also sort of inspired a lot of
researchers in the soviet
union to start thinking about this
concept called parabore
right which is kind of analogous to the
intuitive idea of combinatorial
explosion that you were talking about
that's right
um so but the an interesting thing
is so both this is still a very
practical problem there's whole
you know a whole subfield of computer
science devoted
to trying to minimize circuits now the
problems become a lot more complex
because
they're a lot more they're a lot more
varied costs than just the number of
gates
but still the the process the problem
doesn't become easier it becomes harder
when you have all these different kinds
of costs
and it also has a lot of implications
for complexity
so it's kind of surprising that i think
this problem
is very basic but it's the one one of
the few whose
uh difficulty computational
intractability we understand at least
still
yeah i guess it's not obviously an np
um it depends on exactly how you
formulate it exactly how it's presented
but in some
in some presentations if you have a
compact input
right it's not even clear that you have
short proofs of
of optimality so uh yeah i don't know
exactly what the complexity status of
the problem is
yeah on the other hand um there are some
like
reasons why the problem might not be np
complete
um and also some you know
things like some connections like if you
had
a um a fast algorithm for this problem
you could actually use it
to do things like prove circuit lower
bounds so prove that
other you know a fast algorithm for this
problem shows that other problems
are actually uh limited as far as their
algorithms
that sounds like the uh impressive work
that ryan williams has been uh
so i'm referring to you know uh has been
working on yeah definitely ryan's
definitely involved in this yeah very
remarkable
connections between circuit lower bounds
on the one hand
and complexity classes on the other
yeah so um
so we also brought up and we keep on
mentioning np
should maybe like i don't know who the
audience is going to be
but maybe we should uh define our terms
at some point
um so np so a lot of problems are about
searching for a solution that meets
certain specifications
through a huge space of solutions or
finding the best solution
when you have some kind of clear
objective function so np
is essentially the class of all the
problems that involve search and
optimization
and np-complete means that
if you could solve that one problem you
could solve any problem of that type
so um uh
so i'm just explaining this for the not
for your benefit you certainly know this
but for the benefit of any kind of like
hypothetical viewer here
but um so one of your
your i guess the the
thing that uh the paper that you're the
still is like one of the most cited
in computer science um cited
not a computer science paper that's
cited
not just in computer science but by
scientists of all types
is is your work on mp completeness and
um one thing i was curious about is
sort of the there were like three papers
that that sort of
brought up this area maybe four if you
include
lena levin's work in the soviet union
yeah there was jack edmonds work
on um on matchings
which mentioned the problem the the
problem of p
versus np there was steve cook's work
on showing that there existed
some natural np complete problems and
then there was your paper
showing how prevalent np complete
problems were and showing that a lot of
the problems people
were trying to work on like traveling
sales person
were in fact np complete so how aware
were you uh uh
so what brought this to your attention
dude
well i was quite aware of the work of
jack edmonds in in the 60s
he was actually focused more on np
intersect co-np
i think he took it as self-evident that
p
was different from np and never actually
framed exactly that
question his interest more was in
what he called the principle of the
absolute supervisor which had to do with
um sort of verification of a solution
and uh in in modern terms would be
called the
the uh question of the np interesting
interests like co-np
so jack was an absolute
genius who sort of blazed new trails in
combinatorial optimization i
i think of the first generation
generation as the people
who did linear programming and flows
george dansig fulkerson and so on and
then jack pioneered the next
very rich development non-bipartite
matching metroids
numerous other things and
and and he certainly stressed
the importance of the question of
whether there's a polynomial time
algorithm for these
problems and he demonstrated some
wonderful polynomial time algorithms i
visited him at the national bureau of
standards one day
probably around 1964 or 65
and it was pivotal in my life because in
in the eight hours i spent with him he
just
told me about all of this cornucopia of
wonderful results
um and and so um
i was certainly aware of the um
the issues around polynomial time
computation
and i also
wasn't aware of it at the time but i
read
parts of hartley rogers book on complex
on
computability theory which came out in
the late 60s
and that sort of
got me prepared to think about
reducibilities
because he thought about you know
recursive reduce abilities
and um i think that that sort of planted
a seed that
led me to my work on reductions
um steve cook uh
is a wonderful guy he was at berkeley
um for the we overlapped for two or
three years i guess
i came in the
winter of 1968 and steve
was already there and remained at
berkeley for
probably five years after no three or
four years after that
um and i knew about steve's work
on arithmetic circuits and and the like
but his work on uh np completeness
uh actually appeared uh
he never he and i never had a discussion
of it
i think he had gone off to toronto and
so i learned about his work by
reading his paper so you never really
talked to him directly about this
not at that time only much later yeah we
never no we never
uh i never talked with him directly
about it
at that point but of course i read this
paper where he showed the completeness
of the sat
problem and also the clique problem is
sort of in there
yeah um and i
i sort of had a eureka moment you know
that you know
you know i've seen all these other
problems uh
covering packing matching and so on uh
sequencing and i'll bet that they're
just as hard as that and
so i began to systematically pursue it
and use reduce abilities i actually used
a different kind of reduceability than
steve had used but that's
just a technical point and um
the actual once i decided to do it i
i was familiar enough with the field of
operations research that i knew
what the generic problems were that
ought to be
looked at and finding the reductions was
actually not so difficult they they're
not
there were a few that i had trouble with
i remember that i
i think i had to get a little help from
gene lawler and bob targen on the
hamiltonian circuit problem which
somehow had eluded me
but most of the reductions were fairly
easy to find
but i it was eye-opening for me and
also for many other people that the
great majority of combinatorial search
problems that we encounter
are np-complete it's it's only the rare
exceptions that are notable and are not
then
avoid the mp complete this trap so just
this year
that kind of intuition was formalized
with the proof of the
the dichotomy can occur um
are you are you uh this is i know it for
accounting
oh oh yeah for boolean uh for for
constraint satisfaction for constraint
satisfaction problems
i had a student tom schaefer who was in
at the beginning of that he
he uh classified um
sets of boolean primitives into and and
found that the
dichotomy results um
yeah i i'm more from i i'm not
terribly familiar with that work there's
the analogous work
on the classification of counting
problems
the genie sai has pioneered i'm
familiar yeah these are nice results
they basically say
that all of the problems are split
beautifully into two classes most of
them are
equally hard and the others are equally
easy yeah
very nice yeah um
so um
so you mentioned that you you're working
with some students you actually have
like a very large number of very
successful grad students you've worked
on
and one thing i we were talking about
earlier is that
these students have very varied careers
do you want to talk about
brag about some of your students oh yes
i'm happy to brag about them
my first student was a man named ray
reiter
who uh unfortunately is deceased and
i worked with him during a leave that i
took from ibm and
i should mention that i got my phd at
harvard
in 59 and spent and then spent nine
years at ibm
research which was a wonderful place to
work and in the middle of that i spent i
took a year off to
teach at the university of michigan i
met ray writer and
he has gone on to he went on to very
important work in
artificial intelligence a field that i
really haven't worked in
so my students have done various things
in
networking there's sally floyd and
who's done some of the fundamental work
on
flow control in in the internet and and
uh
and uh phil gibbons um
uh faith ellen has done important work
in distributed computing
um noah nissan and is a genius he's a
founder of
of computational uh economics and game
and game theory game theory and
it was only nominally that i was his
advisor
i learned from him but what basically
had
the the information transfer was from
him
from victim to him and from him to me
so he taught me a lot and i taught him
very little
yeah he taught me a lot too
rajiv madwani also unfortunately
deceased did some wonderful work on
probabilistic analysis of graph
theoretic problems for his thesis
wrote a nice book on randomized
algorithms with
prabhakar raghavan regrettably i
turned down their invitation to be a
co-author of that book that was one of
my major mistakes in life uh rajiv
unfortunately died young but
he he was a guru in in silicon valley
he uh he was a wonderful theoretician
but he also
understood how the valley worked and was
a
great advisor to to entrepreneurs
um let's see who who else
mike luby did fundamental work on
communications and has
started a company and is now uh
now at uh qualcomm very successful
uh barbara simons became president of
the acm
um i could go on there are quite a few
but the the i guess like the thing that
stands out to me is how varied their
careers are oh i didn't even mention the
people who do computational biology
yeah computational biology i never did
as well at that as i
would have liked but i did influence a
number of students who did better than i
did
like dan gustfield and ron shamir and
eric xing who's at
carnegie mellon now
dan was working in that area before it
became trendy i think
dan that's right he pioneered a lot of
the
ideas that would pick up in the in the
um
human genome project that's right that's
right
um he uh uh his his book uh
his uh on um
sequences and so forth is is um
very very notable and he's done a lot of
important work
so what was your philosophy in advising
students
you know how did you and did you
give them projects to work on no never
never i
always wanted them to discover their own
problems
i mean sometimes i gave them a boost i
remember
in some cases i would sort of suggest a
starting problem but
basically i wanted them to follow their
own path of discovery
and
they had different personalities and and
different preferences some of them like
to
do collaborative work with others a few
of them
did collaborative work with me um
i i was pretty i've always been pretty
laissez faire
i was sort of i made myself available
but i
um i i really wanted them to
work things out for the for themselves
and
some were extremely independent noam
nissan didn't really need
an advisor others uh others needed some
uh some some guidance um
and i i try to be encouraging and and
be available as a sounding board um
but i i think the the main thing was was
was to feel out what
style each of them desired and and
and let them pursue that style yeah so
one thing
i remember you're saying when i was a
grad student at berkeley
not your student but a student at the
same time that you were professor
is you said that what makes
um what each researcher needs to do is
find their edge
and i interpret that as finding
something that you're particularly good
at that's kind of
synchronizes with your talents is that
what you meant
exactly yeah so um
in in my case i would say that um
part of my edge was a a good feel
for uh probability theory and not
not measure theoretic probability but
good down-to-earth discrete probability
i was able to
work with with those tools
um i tend to be drawn to
finite problems rather than infinite
problems so i
really like problems where you can do
examples
and one one of my
peculiarities is that instead of going
out and writing programs to
run an algorithm i will sit
like a a slave
executing the algorithm on up examples
to just get a sort of intuitive feel for
what happens like it's that gives you
like
you know if you just look at the input
and output you're not
you're missed the process yeah yeah
that's right that's right
um in general when you read people's
papers they don't reveal the process or
how they were led to what they did
that's too bad i think a good expositor
should
lay out the process um what i'm not
good at is is constructing very
complicated proofs
i would say that i'm not the right guy
to help you check out your proof that p
is unequal to np
no one wants to be that guy
i like to work with people who are
better than i am that that's a big help
well that's the challenge though you
have to find those people you have to
find them yeah so i've worked with some
of the
marvelous scientists
and i've enjoyed that um i've had
wonderful postdocs i must say avi
victorson was my postdoc
and ravi kanan and
elijah fall and others so so that's been
a
very enriching experience i guess
i guess one of my um
good qualities is that i uh
love to teach and and to organize
material
in order to present it cogently in the
class
yeah so you're very famous for that um
did so do you find that you learn a lot
by doing that oh yeah
i mean there's nothing like teaching to
enable you to master a subject
you really have to learn the subject in
order to teach it right and
i think when i first came to berkeley
i really took my teaching very seriously
i treated
each lecture as if it were a command
performance of king lear
yet to really do it right and
i i would be very thoroughly prepared
and by preparing thoroughly i was able
to digress if necessary to answer a
question because i
sort of knew the territory over time
i got busy with other things uh
one of the uh aspects of an academic
life
is is that you get more sort of civic
and community responsibility
you have more letters of reference to
write and so forth
and so um i began to
compromise by standards a little bit and
so in the later years i
wasn't so perfectly prepared and my
teaching ratings dropped a little bit
yeah i think students are becoming much
fussier too
actually one thing about the ecs
department that i belong to at berkeley
the
standards of teaching are incredibly
high
and people take it very seriously i
haven't taught
it's been several years since i taught
because of my duties at simon's i
haven't
had the opportunity to teach classes
or the or the requirement to teach
classes
uh and i'm not sure i would enjoy it in
the present climate where you have to be
a manager of 25 tas
it's true i used to want to
learn all my students names now i want
to learn all the tas names by the end of
the course
exactly my my colleagues seem to
adapt readily to this and to actually
enjoy it i mean
there are positive things about it if
you've been teaching a large
introductory course and you walk across
campus
people will point to you and point you
out but
i i don't think i would enjoy teaching
these
math courses that we're offering
nowadays have you ever written a
textbook or been tempted to write a
textbook
no i haven't again i
even though i was thorough in my lecture
preparation i'm
fundamentally lazy i find that hard to
believe
and um there's a certain amount of the
dog work in writing a book maybe i
overestimated the
the challenge of it uh just getting all
the names right in the index and so
forth yeah
and i've never done that i've written
i've produced some pretty good lecture
notes that could have been turned into
books
yes i think i have some of those
um okay so
um
you know so you when you started
computer science was kind of like
um just defining itself as a field
that's right and you mentioned like
different aspects
you know different feel related fields
that were kind of
all contributed uh there's operations
research there was recursion theory
now called computability theory yeah um
and uh and i guess even like electrical
and computer engineering
right you know electrical engineering
played a role
uh
do you feel like you know
we're so though then at that time people
were like coming together
now i get a sense that maybe the the
field is becoming
breaking up more into specialization yes
and it's harder to communicate do you
have the same sense
absolutely so there there there are
two aspects to your comments
one is about the various influences at
the time i was a student
and the other is about how the field is
branching out currently so
as a student i had never heard the term
computer science but i was in a
computation
laboratory and
i took numerical analysis i took
a number of electrical engineering
courses i was
terrible in the lab i could never make
anything work in the lab in fact if i
can
digress for a moment some years ago i
was lucky enough to get an
honorary doctorate at the university of
pennsylvania
and the person who introduced me at the
ceremony
had been in the lab with me when i was
taking a course on
pulse circuits and he
took time out to marvel that
the idiot the klutz
who had been in this uh in this lab
we've already established that your edge
is not soldering
right it couldn't do anything could
never have done anything worthwhile
um so anyway i took a number of courses
on
um servo mechanisms and control
and so on so it's quite different than
the current theories of course
and um circuit circuit theory
um and the courses i liked most were
those that had to do with probability
and statistics i just
somehow that always resonated with me
um so um
so if you had asked me whether i was a
computer scientist i wouldn't have known
how to answer at that time and i guess
no one would have asked
because no one would have asked that's
true um
but i had a stroke of luck in landing a
job at ibm i went on the market
there were no academic jobs that i could
aspire to at that point
so i interviewed at a number of
companies and ibm was by far the most
appealing and
and i
had to choose between a few different
offers within ibm and i
realized that discrete math was what i
wanted to be doing and so i joined the
switching theory group to
as my first assignment and there
i think
in some sense the field of computer
science was sort of
what ibm did so so in that sense i was
embedded
in it and
i think another influence a little bit
later was
don knuth's work his volume one in
particular
which um sort of
launched the analysis of algorithms as a
as a topic i think up until
seeing knuth's work i had been
pretty naive about step counting and
that's that sort of thing
some algorithms were nice because they
were pretty and i didn't really
get down to analyzing exactly what the
time bounds were
so i learned that partly from knuth
and i followed the results in complexity
theory
michael rabin came to visit the ibm lab
and
we had wonderful conversations
we lived in the same apartment in the
upper reaches of new york city and we
drove
every day for a while to to
the ibm lab and michael would teach me
things
he was great um so
um getting to go to ibm was great
it was a period when ibm had 75
of the computer market and they could
afford to be lavish and just
let people do what they wanted to do
rather than work for clients or
customers
and there were very good people i
learned about integer programming
and learned a little bit of linear
algebra and there's
there are certain tools that you can you
know
that can take you a long way yeah max
low mint cut
linear algebra and turn off bounds and
you know a few all these but goodies
that you can use over and over again
so i learned some of the tricks of the
trade
at ibm i spent very nine happy years
there
what was your question again yeah oh um
so that's like you're talking about how
computer science came together with all
these different
influences yeah there was you know
electrical engineering and like circuit
circuit design then was circuit theory
was part of electrical engineering i
suppose
um and then there was people like
michael raven who were coming from
computability complexity yeah and
um and then donald knuth
sort of like um established the rule
book
yeah um wrote the book a little early
um that sort of like said what what are
we doing in designing algorithms
right um so that's sort of like saying
how the field came together
but same with us go forward like a
number of years
and say do you feel like the the field
is still
cohesive or
is it maybe becoming very specialized
are we about
to uh maybe see the birth of
other areas sort of emerging from recon
recombining different aspects of
existing fields
right well that's definitely happening
so
um for for a while
um one could use a very modest
toolkit of techniques and make some
progress
on interesting computer science problems
and these often were problems
that had a sort of real world relevance
and there were just a lot of things to
be uh
to be done on basic algorithms
but as the field has developed i used to
i used to compare what we were doing in
computer science to
19th century mathematics that it was
still pretty
uh intuitive that you that you could
really understand something about all of
mathematics
and uh and uh of course the frontiers of
mathematics
moved way out so that people in one
specialty
really have trouble communicating with
other specialists right
different parts of mathematics yeah
maybe cows was the last one
who understood it all maybe yeah but you
could you could you could
follow quite a bit of it
back in the 50s 60s and so on
but now different specialties in
theoretical computer science
have become very advanced and and the
frontiers are pretty far out so you
can't just
jump into
let's say
security and privacy or or uh
um cryptography
and and expect to uh to contribute
without
knowing quite a bit of lore or in every
area whether it's
computational algebraic geometry or
spectral analysis or or
[Music]
computational logic the the field has
moved
pretty far out and
i think in a sense if you think of it as
a growing tree
it's gotten to some extent separated
from its roots in practicality
so i think that um
many of the people who uh
in past times would have become research
mathematicians
are now using very advanced mathematical
techniques in the context
of computer science yeah and and
and they're so and they're solving very
hard problems
but problems that have been refined to
the point that their
connection to the practical roots of
computation
are somewhat lost in many cases and
people don't really care that much about
losing those connections because
the fields sort of generate their own
identity
and their own style and open
their own open questions
you also asked about new fields arising
and of course this is also true
the um data sciences data science big
data artificial
artificial intelligence machine learning
right i mean
these these have uh blossomed in the
last
15 to 15 years probably yeah
and especially in the last just in the
very recent past
yeah but maybe this is also like an
opportunity because i think
um uh you know so
um not that i'm an expert on these
things but
with you know ucsd where i'm i'm a
faculty member
is starting a data science major and one
question we're or continually
asking or mainly them continuously
discussing with mohan patruri
is what exactly is data science and
you know what is the scope of data
science what makes something data
science
yeah and
so i think it may be in the same stage
as computer science was in the 50s
where where there was obviously
something happening
but it wasn't clear what the scope of
you know how that would emerge right but
it's it's moving along at a
furious rate so yeah
berkeley and other places are uh
adopting the philosophy that every
undergraduate should be exposed to
whatever it is
maybe the knuth hasn't come along to set
up the ground rules yet
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
um
i think it's not so much what it is
because what it is is really
the uh generation of
of data and the of large bodies of data
and the and the
uh creation of insight from analyzing
that data
so that's what it is it's it's it's the
is driven by the
the influence of the act the
availability of
large data sets in almost any field you
can name
what's less clear is what the
foundations are
what the mathematical foundations are
yeah and it has something to do with
sparsification and dimension reduction
and
all the techniques for for
simplifying large data sets to extract
the essence
it has a lot to do with real time
decision making
certainly has a lot to do with advanced
statistical methods it's sort of the
extension of classical statistics to the
case where you have really large data
sets
it's the size of the data set i mean
certain classical statistics
if you have like large data sets that
are sampled from the same distribution
yeah it should be really good at that
right i think maybe
the the problem is that you have large
data sets in your
with kind of uncertain provenance
exactly
exactly the diversity of the data the
combining of different types of data
yeah the
fact that the data may have been
gathered in a way
that made it not representative of it's
not clear what population you're
sampling from
yeah and the fact that there's so much
data
means that there's an abundance of
possible hypotheses some of which will
just
accidentally seem to be significant yeah
so it's it's kind of class
statistics on steroids if you will and
the problems are very hard and we we
don't really
we don't really know exactly where it's
going there's the related
field of artificial intelligence where
um i mean if you read the billboards as
you drive out to
san francisco airport you'll see that
there are companies that are
offering artificial intelligence to the
world and
hiring at inflated salaries hiring
people to
to do artificial intelligence and it's
as if artificial intelligence is some
magic potion
that a few a few high priests possess it
and
and if you can hire one of those high
priests that that person will be able to
sprinkle his artificial intelligence
knowledge over all the problems of the
world
right so there's an exaggerated
respect for for what it is what it
really is
there is there's been definite success
in solving certain kinds of
classification problems
but first of all it's a far cry from
what the founders of artificial
intelligence meant by the subject
and um you know so the ironic thing
is that if you like go back 20 years ago
even i think
artificial intelligence had gotten a
huge a bad reputation for being
impractical
yeah that's right and
you know an underserved undeservedly bad
reputation
at that time so the pendulum swings
quite a bit
quite quickly right and um
it's also a a dilemma for
people who are used to analyzing
algorithms
because um the
success of some of the deep learning
algorithms has gone far beyond what we
can
what we can analyze yeah um in fact that
sort of touches on another theme which
is
um empirical very empirical validation
of algorithms which is becoming more
more uh prevalent i think in a lot of
areas
so we we've seen um success
in um um
sort of um boolean
minimization and sat solvers
have been successful beyond what we can
explain you've worked a lot on that sort
of thing
yes um
work in failing also failing to explain
it along with everyone else so there's
there's been very striking work by
kevin leighton brown for example where
he
has been able to classify different
types of satisfiability
instances and predict which algorithms
would work well on which of those
right very impressive but completely
empirical
yeah but some sense um you mentioned
work with held
earlier yeah and i think wasn't some of
your work with him
motivated by some of the same questions
uh like the held carp bound
using that to empirically validate um
approximation algorithms yeah i've
always been interested in doing
that my current work is is along those
lines
um yeah we could never
prove anything about much about our
traveling salesman algorithm or the
quality of the
i guess the they're still open questions
about the so-called
health carp bound and there's even
current work on the
asymmetric version of that
the bound as it applies to asymmetric
tsps there's some beautiful
recent work but but um
um i don't i don't
shrink from experimentally
investigating algorithms if i can find
somebody to write the code
yeah so um is
staying like more ground down to earth
being able to
look at concrete instances of problems
part of the reason why you moved into
computational biology
a while back yeah back about
around the turn of the 20th century the
human
i guess maybe around 1995
the human genome project was
bubbling up in its importance and
my colleague gene lawler was working on
related problems and my former student
dan gustfield had
was pioneering that subject
and i sort of i think it was sort of a
machismo thing i
i sort of said to myself gee if they can
do that do that i i can do it too there
are all these combinatorial problems and
i'll just sort of barge in and see what
i can do
and it turns out that
it's not so easy
your theoretical statements
if any that you can make about your
algorithms for analyzing dna sequences
or
protein protein interactions or
regulator regulatory networks
it all depends on how much insight you
can give to the biologist and whether
you can get the intention
the attention of a biologist a lot of it
is just being
in the right place to to
to assist major projects
popularizing your work writing code that
people can
easily use um
and uh frankly uh i i haven't succeeded
to the extent that i would have liked in
in that area so
i i can't i can't say that i've
influenced the
been a big influence on the course of
computational biology
except that i've had a number of
students who have really done well
eric shane ron shamir
and others
but it's a it's a tricky business and
nowadays
you really have to work with a
particular project on particular data
sets
um in the early days the late 90s up
through
maybe 2005 you could sort of work on
generic
problems that made sense
sequence alignment or phylogeny and so
on
but more and more the good work is being
done in
in very concrete contexts with very
particular data sets
to try and understand particular
diseases or or particular mechanisms
within the cell
and you really have to get down and
dirty so to speak
and i i haven't been
paying my dues by trying to do that so
i guess it's sort of where you know
in the 90s people were looking at
particular secret you know
dna sequences trying to unravel them
figure out
what the sequences were yeah now the
goal is to find out
what the purpose of the these
genes are how they interact with all the
other proteins in the cell
right um that's a much more complex and
less defined problem right
yeah it's much more difficult i mean
there are a few
particular uh branches where the
problem formulations are clean enough
that one can continue to
do terrific work tandy warnow for
example has
made a wonderful career in
in phylogeny analysis and sequence
alignment that she's continued to find
new applications new directions and the
problems are
fairly clean
when you get down to
looking at proteins in particular it
gets harder
they have a three-dimensional structure
you
the combinatorics of how the proteins
interact the data is not very clean
there are a lot of impediments generally
to understanding
doing what you might call cell biology
meaning
the investigation of of the control
mechanisms within living cells is just a
messy subject
so do you have any this kind of brings
up the the general question of
you know so traditional theory we sort
of like
expect people to bring the problem
formulations to us
but a lot of part of
making algorithms that actually solve
problems
uh that people want to have solved is
coming up with the right formulation
so do you have any insight into how you
come up with the right formulation of
problems
i'm asking you a tough one a tough one
i would say that again it's uh it's a
matter of uh
getting down in the weeds like if you if
you want to solve
uh problems for uh
of the type that arise in in amazon
or or lyft or uber
or google whether it's advertising or
routing of vehicles or distribution of
goods
you probably have to sit down and
see what's going on and you know right
right right around with the truck
drivers and see what's actually
happening
uh yeah and again it takes a certain uh
dedication yeah but also a lot of
you know there's this this kind of legal
issue a lot of the
the data for the the applications you're
talking about
just now are are um you know um
proprietary you cannot just
get that information yeah um and start
working on it
without having some kind of relationship
with the company yeah
there are still some some classic
problems of of complexity that
can that are very clean and can be
pursued
i think that you've done some you you've
sort of injected new life into
complexity theory by talking about the
strong um
strong exponential time hypothesis and
where you um make a very concrete
assumption about the difficulty of the
satisfiability problem and then
you take that as a hypothesis and and
find out that
it implies all kinds of results about
other problems lower down and complexity
yeah that's a really neat uh
yes discovery yeah but again um
you know so it sort of has the same
shortcoming maybe of
some of the work on mp completeness
which he talks about the worst case
complexity of this problem
yeah or you can even talk about the
average case complexity of the problem
but talking about the typical case
complexity of the problem
where typical means something that
people actually want to solve
yeah as opposed to a random instance or
a worst case scenario that's right
it's so much harder it's so much harder
and and
and that's something that we really need
to cope with um
i think that the work on approximation
algorithms where you get guaranteed to
create polynomial time algorithms for
np-hard problems
that are guaranteed to come within a
certain ratio of optimum
is beautiful work which uses very nice
techniques from
mathematical programming and so on
but it really misses the mark in terms
of relevance in my opinion
because the abounds
that you can prove when you're talking
about an
algorithm that always gives a good
approximation
so much worse than what you can actually
achieve with those problems empirically
and so even though i admire
that line of research i think somebody
has to come along and figure out an
approach that would
have more bearing on as you say the
typical
instances so i want to say
that sometimes you know
sometimes you really care about getting
the the right answer to one percent
right and sometimes you just care about
getting in the right ballpark
that's true and so um
because a lot of times you're using an
approximation algorithm
as kind of a meta algorithm to help
steer another algorithm
and so the cost in being off is like
a small factor in the running time of
your other algorithm
or you mentioned like um uh the circuit
design problem that was successful
well i think that that a lot of those um
the two levels
circuit design you're using like a set
cover
heuristic and so uh it can be off by a
factor of
n but um
when you're talking about an exponential
size circuit
and it's not so bad
yeah that's possible uh there's also the
complexity theoretic work of showing
that it's hard to
um to um
even get polynomial time algorithms
within any
any close factor of the volume and
i admire that work very much and have
been some
real breakthroughs there yeah and that
it's also like one of the bringing us
back to the idea of the synthesis
between
discrete and continuous mathematics
because
there they sort of show that
the best approximation algorithm which
is kind of a discrete concept
can actually be like formulated as uh
the best
uh semi-definite relaxation right and
that's a
more continuous
right version right there so you get
these kind of very
interest you know strange approximation
ratios that are the best achievable
under possible assumptions right that's
a brilliant piece of work
involving uh showing that semi-definite
programming is
in some sense the canonical way to
tackle those problems
what are some of your other favorite
developments in
in computer science well we've already
touched on some of them
i i've been very impressed with the
the spectral graph analysis and all of
the things that you can do with
linear algebra and spectral computation
um
i i think the the reductions from
uh from the strong exponential time
hypothesis to prove various concrete
results about the
about real real life problems are very
very relevant very interesting um
some some of my results have been
superseded by
better results obtained recently so
there's some
very nice work using discrepancy theory
which gets a better bound for
the then karmicara and i were able to
obtain for the
impacting problem and
i was happy to see that the linear
programming formulation for the
asymmetric tsp that i worked on with
michael held was the starting point for
some new
exciting results about
solving the asymmetric tsp within a
constant factor
however and another aspect of current
day complexity theory
is that we're
sometimes getting results that uh
depart pretty far from anything that
anybody would use in practice
so i mean the practical solution of the
tsp
is quite a different game from the
computation of those bounds
there are also what richard lipton has
called
galactic algorithms algorithms that are
very good asymptotically but not be
but not useful within any practical
range
that okay i should say like um
uh when i was in grad school people said
that the strassen
matrix multiply algorithm was one of
those and yet
i i believe you know so you know
one reason why people thought that
this these algorithms won't be useful
for
um
for um input sizes that are practical
is that input sizes that are practical
are so much bigger now
right than they were true 20 years ago
30 years ago
right so so maybe at some time in the
future the
uh the work of uh winograd at all on
matrix multiplication will also be
practical exactly
yeah it's possible um
so um
there was one other thing i wanted to
talk about but now i'm i'm forgetting it
oh so um
when you were starting research
in you know that in the field that
eventually became computer science
did you imagine computer science uh
as being at all like it is today and
you know what ways is it surprising to
you and what ways
would you uh
did you like anticipate developments
well the
you know there's a whole world of
computation and digital communication
that we've
constructed which sort of lives
side by side with the physical world and
the laws governing this world of
computation are
relevant to everyone everybody
spends time with digital devices and
benefiting from
what you what you can do with them i i
certainly didn't
anticipate that i mean nobody did when i
was a
graduate student i mean thomas watson
senior said that there wouldn't be any
need for more than five computers in the
world
now you have five in your office
probably five in your pocket five in
your pocket now
um that's no i had no
no conception i mean my mother had told
me that data processing was very
important
but i had no sense of how what a
sweeping effect it was going to have on
on society
so so that
that comes as a complete surprise and of
course there's a lot to worry about too
um just as one example people don't read
deeply anymore
they have so many sources of information
that um they sort of uh uh
give me skim everything and and uh the
art of
deep reading or certainly
poetry and fields like that are are no
longer
no longer have the the stature and the
and the
um providence that they have had in the
past and i think that's
i think we've become shallower but more
facile we're producing a generation of
people who could be
great air traffic controllers because
they can multitask
and respond quickly to
digital stimuli and so on but there's
something
lost as well so i of course
nobody anticipated all of that
in terms of theoretical computer science
it's been brought home to me at the
simons institute where we
cast our attention um
on different themes every semester and
and bring together the experts in
in those thematic areas every semester
i find myself behind the curve because
you know
the cryptographers come in and they know
all about
the latest developments and computing in
the cloud and so on and it's all new to
me and then the next semester
it's design and economics and a new
bunch of experts come in
and i'm constantly behind the curve
and discovering that the frontiers have
gone out
very far and this is of course wonderful
yeah
but uh somewhat intimidating
um what did
you know so like a new grad student is
in the same situation
right in some sense they're like 40
years behind yeah
so what advice would you give to a grad
student starting out
how to not be intimidated
that's a tough question i i would
suggest
not losing contact with the real world
of applications
and not um not simply jumping into
somebody of theory that
because it's there but but actually
thinking about what might
accomplish what might matter what might
lead to
an accomplishment in the world it's
probably good to have a
secondary interest besides theory yeah
um
but um you know we've seen
many generations of graduate students
coming through and thriving and it
continues berkeley is one of the places
that keeps producing
fantastic graduates so somehow they're
managing i think being open to working
with other people
not being jealous of your results but
you know
being out there and collaborating
is very important for students learn a
lot of mathematics
one of my regrets is that there are
certain branches of mathematics where
i'm
fairly ignorant and that could have been
relevant for me and
i would have taken more math instead of
those
engineering courses that i took if i had
known so
often like students say
what area of mathematics should i learn
to do computer science
and i think my my answer is
well look at all the areas that have
been applied successfully to computer
science
and learn something else sound something
else like maybe
maybe maybe it's apology it's going to
come to the floor
right although i know i already know
some applications of topology
right um so
yeah string but it's relatively
it's relatively untapped right so
because i think one one way of getting
an
edge is to know something that other
people don't that's true
and you don't know what's relevant into
you know if you don't know an area you
don't know whether or not it's relevant
right that's why i like this
this optimization program that we're
running
at simon's because i think it's bringing
people together with different
who will learn from one another with
very different skills yeah
so um how is your experience what what
do you
you know what you think of the role of
the simon's institute
in theoretical computer science today
and what was your experience as director
it's been successful far beyond my my
dreams and that's the work of
many many people on our on our staff and
the other scientists who've been in the
leadership
team of the simon's institute
it's really become the place where
people want to go to
gather and advance the field i think
it's bringing
collaborative research to a different
level
for for me it's been mixed because
um i
somehow discovered that i'm
not meant to be a manager exactly
but there have been been enough
skillful colleagues to cover my
deficiencies so it hasn't gone too badly
now i'm yearning to get back and and
really focus on
research and the way that i have what's
your upcoming project
or do you haven't have you decided well
i've been working on a certain
problem called the group steiner problem
it's one of the classical
np-hard problems and i've got some ideas
about
algorithms which i have tested
partly through computer programs and
partly from doing
lots of little examples and i think i
might
have some good ideas there and i'd like
to pursue that
i'll continue to be interested in
bioinformatics i'll continue to be
interested
in foundations of data science
i'm told that you're going to be on the
other side
as a program organizer for an upcoming
program yes
yes this began a few years ago when i
heard a talk
by um an astronomer
named joshua bloom
who was also very skilled in computer
science and machine learning
and he talked about robotic astronomy
uh he talked about the fact that
um astronomers don't
really point the telescope anymore tell
us
the directions that the telescope takes
the
areas of the sky that are chosen for
examination
are chosen by algorithms and these
algorithms have to take into
account massive amounts of data that
they
that the telescopes are generating and
decide in real time which
of the many images they've taken to
throw away
which ones to keep and analyze and how
to use the results of that analysis to
decide
what's likely to be interesting and
where to look next
uh so that's an example
of a problem
where massive amounts of data are being
gathered the data
some of the data has to be discarded
other has to be other parts of it have
to be analyzed deeply
and there's a a feedback loop where the
results of the analysis of the data
affect the next decisions and which data
is going to be derived
so also like a challenge to traditional
statistics
in that you're the way you're gathering
the data isn't independent of the data
so trying to reach conclusions
you have to worry about uh sort of
i guess this like bias
towards your you're confirming your own
hypotheses
yeah i hadn't explicitly thought about
that but that is
an important complication so it turns
out that there are many other
areas where a similar
feedback between rapid decision making
and action
occur it's in managing the energy grid
and
certain aspects of managing urban
transportation
in making a quick response to
emergencies such as earthquakes
just a lot of different application
areas which
in terms of their domains of application
are very different from one another
another example is the large hadron
collider
at geneva where um
um nuclear collisions are being uh
observed and processed but also like
even like uh
self-driving vehicles self-driving
vehicles yeah it's closely related to
control theory and
yeah and the like and so this
uh this program um that's coming up in
the spring will bring together
uh domain scientists in
those various domains astronomers
earthquake seismologists
etc with
people who will be using
statistics and mathematical modeling
and control theory and streaming
and real-time analysis
to try to study this decision-making
process
so it's a it's a rich stew of different
topics
but somewhat somewhat diffuse
compared to the usual rather focused
program at simon so
it's not clear it's clear that we're
going to have a lot of fun and there'll
be a lot of interesting
topics discussed whether
some universal methodologies
are derived is an open question you know
if you're looking at
areas as distinct as robotic astronomy
on the one hand and
scheduling uh traffic lights on the
other hand
uh you know it's unclear whether um
the intersection of all those areas has
something substantial
but we'll explore it there's also like
the social issue you know
a lot of the simon's programs have the
theme of bringing together researchers
from different communities
but once you're there there's
you have to fight the inertia of people
working with people they already are
kind of familiar with using language
they're already
familiar with yeah we'll have to deal
with that
of course it goes without saying that we
owe it all to
the wisdom of jim and marilyn simons in
um seeing something worthy in what we
were trying to do here
and making a very substantial
investment and and uh being encouraging
all along with saying nice things to us
about how we're doing and
and uh showing continued uh interest
and uh it's wonderful to see
such a philanthropic attitude from
people in the real world who understand
the value of fundamental science
it's been the privilege of my life to
be in a position to help with help the
team to
make it work and i'm very gratified that
it seems to be working
out so well
[Music]
bye